dass sie ein baby hat hat die 16-jährige
noch nicht richtig begriffen sie liebt
ihr wildes teenager leben weiter und
[Musik]
damit jetzt konstanter wir leute die
machen heute einen ausflug in eine zeit
von hdtv die eigentlich gewissermaßen
vor youtube stattgefunden hat wie werden
sie mich heute ein video anschauen was
allem anschein nach aus einer zeit
stammt als hilf mir und konsorten noch
nicht regelmäßig youtube hochgeladen
haben und ein bisschen älter ist aber es
ist wirklich schockierend muss man sagen
und es zeigt so die seite von
deutschland die man manchmal eigentlich
ganz gerne vergessen möchte aber ja der
titel lautet 14 jährige teenie mutter
ist extrem vorsichtig und ja allein der
titel macht schon sehr betroffen
das video wird ist sicherlich das
gleiche tun wahrscheinlich mal ein
schulschwänzerin asara ist mit 14
schwanger geworden
doch statt sich um ihre tochter zu
kümmern fangen hat die junge mutter
lieber mit ihrer clique
worauf sollte zählen worauf soll ich
jetzt hier zuerst angehen das ist
einfach so viele dinge die falsch laufen
aber beide male das kann erst mal gut
sein dass ich gerade ein bisschen was
zensieren musste weil wissen wir ja auf
youtube und was youtube macht ist wenn
auf youtube sachen gezeigt werden die im
echten leben 80.000 mal jeden tag in
deutschland passieren nämlich dass
minderjährige sich mal ne gibt beziehen
rauchen oder bier dann ist das wie
gesagt in deutschland gang und gäbe auch
wenn es verboten ist aber sobald es auf
youtube passiert kriegt man dafür ein
strike und deswegen musste ich dann
erstmal zensiert
[Musik]
das macht wirklich einfach betroffen ich
möchte das jetzt echte lebensgeschichte
es ehrlich nicht zwingend mehr hilft mir
wo man wollen wir alles wie erdacht ist
man kann am ende immer noch darauf
zurückgreifen so zu sagen es ist halt am
ende nicht echte ja das ist echt ihr
kind muss wirklich unter diesen
bedingungen groß werden
obama scheint also simone tag schafft es
die sozialpädagogin aus dem aufmüpfigen
teenager an mama zu machen
also nein also wir werden sehen
aber mal ganz ehrlich ja das macht
wirklich betroffen das schockiert so was
zu sehen und andererseits zeigt es aber
auch so unangenehm diese gespräche sind
die er mit seinen eltern hat wenn sie
eine aufwändige die sind wichtig weil
sonst kommst am ende wenn du pech als in
so einer situation dann sind wirklich
alle mal in diesem mehrfamilienhaus lädt
die teenager mutter sarah die schülerin
wurde mit 14 jahren schwanger
ohne witz es tut mir einfach so leid es
tut mir person kann es nicht wirklich
anders sagen ich meine andererseits kann
ich jetzt auch nicht so tun aus meiner
brille heraus als wäre ihr ihrem leben
jetzt das schlimmste auf der ganzen welt
vielleicht hat sich damit der perfekt
arrangiert aber für mich ist das
wirklich so eine worst case meine
eigenen wahrnehmung nach heute muss
jeder für sich entscheiden
das ist dicker das so nicht
sarah konnte bislang keiner bindung zu
ihrer tochter aufbauen
diese kümmert sich als sarahs mutter
jutta um das baby die 45-jährige ist
genervt von der situation und können wir
dir könnt ihr bitte mal jetzt zu bringen
wo man ein bisschen lachen kann das ist
ja wirklich bis dieser krankheit
das ist so weit weg von allem was ich in
meinem leben machen würde oder was ich
mir im leben gericht hatte das ist
geisteskrank und am kurzen sonst kann
aufschlagen
warum braucht man denn einem haushalt
und 1 kind dabei ist und daran sie wurde
bei ihrem ersten mal schwanger
seitdem hat sie vom vater des kindes
nichts mehr gehört
zur zeit wird er vom jugendamt gesucht
es ist so es ist wirklich unglaublich
leute das ist doch unglaublich oder
sag mir bitte den kommentaren seid ihr
auch so schockiert wie ich oder was
denkt ihr euch wenn diese folge sie kann
ich darüber lachen aber ich denke ich
wirklich an alles schicksal von dem kind
die 16-jährige will wie so oft feiern
gehen
das kann doch nicht die weiter sie sagt
ja ja ich gehe heute abend feiern
erster punkt wo man sich denken kann
junge mutter das kind ist wie als sechs
monate sie ist das einzige elternteil
was da ist der vater ist in lam pakistan
ist schon verschwunden und das einzige
detail sagt dass man solch gehört anfang
okay sagt ihre mutter
nur wenn du den ganzen tag mit ihr baby
verbringen ist dann sagt sie aber ich
habe doch schon gestern mit dem baby
verbracht ach so ja nicht dann ist okay
ja wenn du gestern schon baby pakistan
kümmert sich hat der weihnachtsmann
denken dass das stimmt aber auch das ist
aber auch so also man kann jetzt sie
nicht nur zu 1000 prozent in die
verantwortung in weiß ich ja selbst
wochen kennt so da ist auch zum ganz
großen teil auch die mutter dran schuld
muss man so klar sagen heute die mutter
ist da auf jeden fall im erheblichen
umfang mit schuld weil sie ihre tochter
nicht angemessen aufgeklärt hat
vielleicht auch nicht richtig erzogen
hat in irgendeiner richtung weil in
anderen haushalten passiert sowas nicht
die ihre kinder vielleicht anders
erziehen die verantwortung für das kind
bleibt komplett an mutter jutta engel
die dafür sogar ihren job aufgegeben hat
für sarah eine selbstverständlichkeit
ist wie heißt das kind hat nina ich
hoffe du bist dieses kind bekommt
einfach in so einen haushalt rhein wo
wirklich alles aber auch wirklich von a
bis z alles schief läuft nichts ist da
wie geregelt gut geregelt so wie es
eigentlich sein sollte
es ist einfach alles anstatt sich
liebevoll um ihre tochter zu kümmern und
zur schule zu gehen betrinkt sich an
sarah jeden tag mit ihren freunden
die haben kein verständnis für ihre
situation erst mal kurz ein blick in den
kommentaren wieder etwas an wollte dazu
sagen dass wir heute eher zu
pflegeeltern kommen wäre viel besser
wird also schwer so etwas zu sagen aber
dass das ganzen rückt schon zu wissen
wie so ein comic leute das wirklich ein
comic wo einfach jemand dem comic
zeichner gesagt hat das mach mal einen
comic wo alle menschen die in diesem
comic auftauchen einfach komplett rein
scheißen okay die macht einfach alles
falsch machen wir so ein comic dann
würde so was bei rauskommt
ihr argument gegen babyklappe tja das
ist über so thema argument gegen
babyklappe ist ja wer weiß wo das kind
landet ja wir wissen aber auf jeden fall
wo das kind jetzt ist nur von hat sie
ihr erstes mal gehabt und wurde auch
gleich direkt von osama welche mit
kontinuität aber schon vielleicht einmal
haben wir es nicht
das ist was ist das schon was ist das
denn
sag mir bitte leute was das soll ich
fühle mich verarscht
nicht immer habe ich vermutet aber schon
immer die ist schon klar dass die worte
immer und immer dasselbe wort sind die
gleichen bedeutung ok man kann nicht
immer was machen und nicht immer
gleichzeitig was machen
der vater der kleinen ist noch während
der schwangerschaft untergetaucht ist er
wieder aufgetaucht
warum warum zeigen dabei simbach ist ja
den bach oder wie soll hier für den
lacher leute aber ich bin kein arm ist
immer noch unter wasser
und dass sie ein baby hat hat die
16-jährige noch nicht richtig begriffen
sie liebt ihr wildes teenager leben
weiter
[Musik]
wie viel wirklich kontinuierlich die
worte für sowas leute wie kann man so
unverantwortlich sein wenn das wirklich
ein assist leute dann ist das eine war
das ist eigentlich eine unterhaltung das
ist eigentlich wartungs fernsehen
es ist eine warnung davor dass man auf
seine kinder nicht acht gibt ja damit
meine ich jetzt schon ihre mutter ja
also die die oma von dem kleinen dass
man auch seine kinder nicht gibt ja erst
mal so machen lässt weil sie ja kann ja
können sie einmal frei entwickelt es ist
irgendwie so absurde so ein bisschen zu
lachen aber es ist auch ist auch eine
krasse dass man so ein bisschen ein
trauerspiel das macht für mich noch mal
wirklich tausendmal deutlicher auch für
euch hoffen sich auch dass man wirklich
nur kinder bekommen sollte wenn man an
den punkt in seinem leben ist dass man
dem kind eine gute zukunft bieten kann
jetzt not found und alle jungen mütter
da draußen manchmal spielt das leben ein
bisschen anlass aber die allermeisten
habe die entscheidung dann auch selbst
in der hand und ich glaube wir sollten
sich schon so nicht danach richten
aber da könnt ihr auch wenn ihr wollt
für zehn jahre wird eher davon abraten
ich schreibe auch mal in die kommentare
leute und dietrich vor schließlich auch
hier oben könnte meinen knarre
abonnieren bleibt stabil bleibt
schwanger mit 14
wir sehen uns in zwei tagen wieder
herein